[Music]
dad
what did you do
[Music]
around about the early mid point of this
first season
we begin to see the first hints that
there is more to margot than meets the
eye
she's not a passenger in this story
what did you tell chewie about us
mosquito coast came to me and i just
kept the script by my bedside
and read it over the months and never
did a casting because i was afraid that
i loved it too much that i
didn't want to lose the part so here's
what's going to happen
margo's got this killer streak in her
and what i wanted to show in episode
four especially is that
you can see that when things are bad
she's like an assassin
a very elegant silent one
i've always considered her the patriarch
of the family she's the one who's
probably the most level
the most thoughtful and also the most
empathetic at the children
i'm a mom always thinking about the
worst thing that could possibly happen
to them
ally is sort of this slightly
hyperactive
bouncy child he's incredibly facile at
manipulating people as he's looking them
in the eye and being dead honest with
them
hey i told you it's going to be an
adventure ali
exemplifies an element of the american
dream
wherein that hurricane of optimism and
forward movement becomes a kind of
blindness
to the needs of what might be around
he's always thinking that the grass is
greener because to him it is
and he constantly searches for that part
of life in
episode four and is confronted with some
truths about himself
and is humiliated which is an element
justin
didn't only accept but celebrate and
pushed you want to run away from america
but you can't
the way you think you can buy people the
way you think you can buy anything you
want
you are america he's got this very
american pioneer spirit of we're just
going to set off
and we're going to find our shangri-la
elsewhere
there's a tension between optimism
and theft in this constant need
always to look at the next valley
there's always the next place to go
it's always going to be better
you